let's move on to tunisia now where a
group of political parties has announced
a coalition to oppose the president
the group says that kaiseid has lost his
legitimacy accusing him of a coup
last week the president announced he
would rule by decree and ignore parts of
the constitution that's after he sacked
the prime minister and suspended
parliament in july so he says his
actions were necessary to counter
economic and political crises
and let's get more on this we can bring
in that shinri falcati in tunis he's a
political commentator and former
parliamentary
officer so this new coalition has been
formed
what could happen next
well what could happen next uh maybe
we'll know it in a few days in the um
let's say
the picture is quite uh now becomes more
and more clearer in tunisia with the
president gathering all the powers and
opposing him political parties are
trying to gather whether for example the
four actual political parties
that are
mainly center-left
parties three of them that are the
cattle and the democratic current
and
uh also
uh
the republican party in addition to
maybe a a kind of right-wing and liberal
party effectus they are trying to gather
and maybe you will see another let's say
and others joining them a few days ago
the secretary general of the uh workers
party the former communist party has
said that there are talks for example
with the democratic current and we will
observe for sure a coalition that is at
the same time against nava and the
former ruling parliamentary coalition
and also against uh president aissai
authoritarian derive
as they call it
and as it's obviously seen now by the
last presidential order uh 117. okay so
what but
what i'm asking really is is what what
can their tactics be now so they want uh
the cons the country's a constitution to
be respected and parliament to be
reinstated but how can they make that
happen
uh
actually uh it's quite clear if they
count on the popular support the popular
support is rather with
balancing toward mr said it's quite
obvious even obvious even according to
recent polls but maybe with
with the deep economic crisis that we
are going to see the effects
of it in the upcoming weeks and months
they could seize maybe the opportunity
to show that unfortunately even by a
power grab even by uh
gathering all the powers president side
is unable to fight the real crisis of
the tunisians that are social problems
economy etc
and maybe tunisians after having this
crisis and losing a lot of their
let's say
purchase power and economic privileges
they will they have also lost
unfortunately maybe some of their
freedoms with this power grab so that's
maybe could be their tactics in the
upcoming months and weeks but if they
can't only now on the popular sport
popular support even according to recent
polls is in favor of president's high
decision so far
so how threatened in your view is
kaiseid's position
excuse me could you please appreciate
the question how threatened is kai
syed's position do you think
i think eyesight position is threatened
so far by the economic issues that we're
facing we've seen some
delays in for example the salaries of
some of the school school teachers and
yesterday the salary of retired people
of or part of them that's what that that
were the talks even on social media
and especially with international
support uh you know rumors uh for
example yesterday
senator murphy op-ed in the connecticut
mirror said it quite clear that now we
must reconsider the american aid
security aid package indonesia if kaisai
is still
not willing to go back to the democratic
path
so maybe
the economic crisis and in addition to
international pressures
and these coalitions here and there that
are that are forming uh could maybe in
the few weeks put a lot and more and
more pressure on president's side but so
far
the population is with him
and i think i've said it quite a few
times even on al jazeera if and if an
election has to be held today or
tomorrow
he would win it uh since the first round
uh sorry if al-qaeda will leave it there
for time thanks very much indeed